when figuring out which line should be
in the final file first I look at the
lines that are the same in both versions
line B is in both so it should be on the
final list it may have been there at the
beginning of the day and neither of them
removed it or possibly both Jake and
Rachel added it independently
either way we definitely want it the
same thing is true for D now let's look
at some that are different
Rachel's file contains a but Jake's file
doesn't there are a few different ways
that this could have happened maybe the
original file didn't contain a and
Rachel added it in that case we do want
a in the final version but it's also
possible that the original line did
contain a and Jake deleted it in that
case the final version shouldn't contain
a it might seem like it would be safest
to just include a since you can always
delete it later but remember that these
letters could be representing code so
reading a deleted line could cause a bug
so without any more information can't
really tell whether a should be in the
final version or not so we mark it as
unknown we can see that the same
reasoning applies to C and the opposite
is true for E it's in Jake's file but
not Rachel's meaning that either he
added it or Rachel deleted it since we
can't tell these apart we don't know
whether we should include it or not